Queen Elizabeth II Britain's longest
reigning monarch has died after 70 years
on the throne at the age of 96.
and it is somehow even sadder than a lot
of us thought it would be so sad that I
I had to come back on and do a bonus
segment I've already done my show for
the day I'll have another show tomorrow
but this is
World historic news and news that people
not just in the United Kingdom but
people all around the world can't take
their eyes off of the fact that this
very nice very aged German lady actually
of German extraction and although she
was the Queen of England
that she died at a ripe old age
is leaving people so so sad and it's not
I think just because she was a very nice
lady who did a very nice job for a very
very long time I don't even think it's
just because she lived such an
extraordinary life the first Prime
Minister over whom she reigned was
Winston Churchill the first American
President whom she met as Queen of
England was Harry Truman that's not even
that I think is why I think the reason
why people are so affected by her death
is because it feels as though she was
the last one the last connection to
to Western civilization at its height
the last connection to a generation that
is gone a generation that that puts
service above personal interest and a
generation that that
valued and exemplified and and put into
their very lives the the heights of
Western culture
and civilization
that that's what it feels like to me at
least I think that's what it feels like
to a lot of people service was at the
heart of This Woman's life she never
retired she never quit her job
she she kept working right up until the
very end she just received the Britain's
new prime minister just days ago
in an absolutely
a
amazing work ethic and it's what she
promised at the the very beginning of
her Reign when when Elizabeth was I
believe
21 years old she promised this would
have been in 1947.
she promised that she would give her
absolute utmost in service of her
countrymen and of her country and of her
God
from my 21st birthday I welcome the
opportunity to speak to all the peoples
of the British Commonwealth and Empire
wherever they live whatever race they
come from and whatever language they
speak
I declare before you all that my whole
life whether it's been long or short
shall be devoted to your service
and to the service of our great Imperial
family to which we all belong
but I shall not have strength to carry
out this resolution alone
unless you join in it with me as I now
invite you to do
I know that your support will be
unfailingly given
God helps me to make good my vows
and God bless all of you who are willing
to share in it
it's one thing for a 21 year old woman
who becomes the queen
seemingly accidentally it's not as
though she had always been in line to
the throne in fact she only became the
Queen of England because her Uncle
Edward VIII abdicated in her Uncle
Edward VII abdicated because in many
ways he was the opposite of Queen
Elizabeth he prioritized his own
personal preferences he prioritized his
own Leisure and his own lower desires
he wanted to marry an American divorcee
this was not possible because the the
Monarch in England is not only the head
of state but also head of the Church of
England this was not permitted certainly
not at the time
and so when he Cho when he had to choose
between his personal preferences and his
lusts and his desires and his duty he
chose his personal preferences and then
Elizabeth's father comes to the throne
George VI then when he dies she becomes
the queen
and it's easy to say when you're 21
years old I dedicate myself to service I
will never stop serving my country
but to actually do it
is is what is so amazing
to actually do it not in in the
spotlight all the time not constantly
receiving Applause of course the queen
was admired for her entire life but
that's not where that sort of work
happened that's not where forget even
the work the commitment the sacrifice
the duty every second of this lady's
life in service of her country anytime
there was any conflict between her
personal choices and her duty this woman
chose her Duty she did it in those Quiet
Moments the quiet and steady and
determined and constant service that is
a far more difficult thing
and Queen Elizabeth elaborated on these
themes in one of her most famous
addresses ever that would have been 10
years after her her promise of service
in 1957 in her first Christmas broadcast
which was broadcast on television Queen
Elizabeth
it
put the the matter of Duty and service
and the monarchy and the whole British
form of government and the whole body
politic in Britain put it in into the
context of this rapidly changing world
where you had rapidly changing
Technologies like the television but you
had rapidly changing social mores New
Perspectives against the monarchy
against tradition against the the
British Nation as it was known you've
come out of the second world war and
their Queen Elizabeth
explains how to make sense of it all in
the modern world
I very much hope that this new medium
will make my Christmas message more
personal and direct
it's inevitable that I should seem a
rather remote figure to many of you
a successor to the kings and queens of
History
someone whose face may be familiar in
newspapers and films
but who never really touches your
personal lives
but now at least for a few minutes I
welcome you to the Peace of my own home
that it's possible for some of you to
see me today
is just another example of the speed at
which things are changing all around us
because of these changes
I'm not surprised that many people feel
lost and unable to decide what to hold
on to and what to discard
how to take advantage of the new life
without losing the best of the old
but it's not the new inventions which
are the difficulty
the trouble is caused by unthinking
people who carelessly throw away ageless
ideals as if they were old and outworn
machinery
they would have religion thrown aside
morality and personal and public life
made meaningless
honesty accounted as foolishness
and self-interest set up in place of
self-restraint
at this critical moment in our history
we will certainly lose the trust and
respect of the world
if we just abandon those fundamental
principles which guided the men and
women who built the greatness of this
country and Commonwealth
today we need a special kind of Courage
not the kind needed in battle
but a kind which makes us stand up for
everything that we know is right
everything that is true and honest
we need the kind of Courage that can
withstand the subtle Corruption of the
cynics
we need the kind of Courage that can
withstand the subtle Corruption of the
cynics and I think this is another
reason why people are so affected by
This Woman's death all over the world is
because our culture is just mired in
cynicism
our culture is just mired in this this
distrust of anything high or Noble
any claims of Truth and any
any kind of dignity at all we just live
in such an undignified Shameless culture
now
when you think of the way that people
speak
in in public life on television the way
that people speak even from high
political office
the sorts of things I don't even I don't
even want to Sully
this moment
in which we're talking about
Queen Elizabeth's Life and Legacy by
discussing the present troubles in the
American government but you think of the
kinds of people running the American
government the Shameless debauche
disgusting things that they do and that
they do publicly not even that they're
caught in a scandal they post
photographs of all sorts of
of of disorder
you think what in that culture you you
had
a handful of people and probably most
notable among all of them Queen
Elizabeth
who who stood there as a reference point
to say no it doesn't have to be this way
you actually can conduct yourself with
dignity you can aim at something higher
that that that line from that Christmas
speech the trouble is caused
it's not caused by the technology it's
not that we're saying that we CA we
conservatives or we traditionalists or
we I don't know these days you might say
we normal people who just think things
have gone a little bit wrong and we'd
like to recover some of what we've lost
it's not that we want to just freeze
time in the past that's not it it's not
even that we we hate technology that
we're luddites or something
you can use technology to to some good
can be used for evil but it can be used
often to some good Queen Elizabeth gave
us that speech on television that's the
reason we can watch it right now
that's not where the trouble lies
the trouble is caused by unthinking
people who carelessly throw away ageless
ideals as if they were old and outworn
machinery
it's so common today to hear glib
flippant shallow people
say what you still believe
X Y and Z idea come on man it's 2022.
come on it's 2022 and the Very fact that
that chronology has progressed must mean
that you can't believe such a thing
anymore
as though there were no Eternal truths
you still believe in marriage and family
and Country and God and responsibility
before all of those things
come on man it's 20 22. no some ideals
or ageless and Queen Elizabeth made
clear what she meant by those ageless
ideals she said that these people these
unthinking people
who carelessly throw away the ages like
the ideals
they would have religion thrown aside
morality
in personal and public life made
meaningless honesty counted as
foolishness and self-interest set up in
place of self-restraint
Queen Elizabeth was not some partisan
she was a true head of state a queen of
the whole country it's difficult for
those of us who don't don't have such a
figure to really make sense of we think
well you know was she a conservative or
a liberal was she a democrat or a
republican what is she well these
problems are not just the problems of
the left
the left causes a lot of these problems
there's no question about that
and the Very term the left comes from
the French Revolution and the people who
sat on the left of the National Assembly
were the ones who wanted to get rid of
the king and attack the church so yes
the left drives a lot of these problems
but not all of them
those who would have religion thrown
aside I know plenty of people on the
right who would have religion thrown
aside who at least wouldn't take it
seriously
those who would have morality and
personal and public life made
meaningless how many people who call
themselves conservative who call
themselves in the right wing
do you know who say well we can't
legislate morality well you're what you
think is good maybe someone else thinks
is bad we can't we can't get the
government involved no no we can't say
anything about morality it's not just
the left doing it's the right sometimes
too
honesty counted as foolishness and
self-interest set up in place of
self-restraint
I know plenty of people especially in
the kind of
business first right wing you know the
people who only care about GDP don't
care about anything else the ones who
want to get rid of this the social
issues ignore the social and cultural
issues they're the sort of ones who say
well I'm just gonna I'm just in it to
get my own profit self-interest greed is
good
that kind of nonsense
that's a right-wing problem too not just
a left-wing problem it's it's why people
are so affected by This Woman's death
it's because we know that what she stood
for and exemplified and personified
is is largely lost not just on one side
of the political aisle or the other it's
just it's just kind of lost people don't
have it anymore now I think there is an
inkling the very fact that people are so
so moved by her life
so affected by her death I think reminds
us that there is a longing for this the
fact that you're you're seeing trends of
of younger people going back to churches
and going back to churches that are
specifically Orthodox lowercaseo you
know that take the religion seriously
that are traditional
I think that tells you that we look back
and we say huh maybe maybe all this
change wasn't so good necessarily
at least not all of it was good I think
this is probably going to be Elizabeth's
lasting Legacy
to make people think in our shallow age
to make people think twice
this shallow age we live in where we're
convinced that all monarchy is terrible
all monarchy is terrible
all democracy is good then you look
around some of our democracies the very
people who are so quick to invoke our
democracy by they seem like some of the
worst rulers of them all and very often
what is called a democracy is very often
just an oligarchy in disguise
we look at someone like Elizabeth and we
say huh
maybe that I was told monarchy was so
bad but but that lady seems to be
rolling a lot better than than some of
the people in our so-called democracy
maybe it turns out that uh when you get
rid of one set of Elites you don't get
rid of Elites period you're just you get
a different set and sometimes a much
worse set of Elites maybe people have to
think twice Beyond a monarchy
just a tradition
we live in this glib age we say oh
that's the past we hate the past well
come on we're in the new future we have
cool little gadgets on our on our wrist
and we can get our emails on our wrist
we're so much better and smarter
everything's gotten better
we look around and we say well I don't
know
anyone living right now
would you say that anyone yourself
included are you living a life as good
as Queen Elizabeth
no you don't have castles you don't have
palaces you don't have guards but so
what
I'm saying your personal comportment
money aside
money money can't buy class and very
often the wealthiest people in the world
are are the most miserable they're the
ones who die early of all sorts of drug
overdoses and degeneracy so money's not
going to fix it would you
would you say right now that there are
people who are living a life as good as
that woman
probably not
probably not why is that
because we live in the modern world and
we say the modern world is so much
better you know because we can like have
sex all the time with whoever we want
and we can do whatever drugs we want
they're all getting legalized and we
don't need to really work all that hard
you know and we can get we can just kind
of get whatever we want on demand
without really waiting or patience or
any virtue is that is that making for a
better world no no I don't think it is
I don't know that the world in 2022
is is so much better than it was in
1957.
or 1947 when when Elizabeth gave those
speeches
in many ways the world is much worse
I think this might be her lasting Legacy
a just this this thought
that maybe everything old isn't bad and
maybe everything new isn't so great and
maybe there is a way
to age
gracefully
the woman aged so gracefully
and she didn't get the constant nip talk
and she didn't try to turn herself into
a Kardashian she physically aged very
gracefully and she aged gracefully in
her entire person
and she embodied her role her role as
the Queen herola's Mother her role as
grandmother her role as great
grandmother her role is head of state
her role as head of the church
the Church of England she she did all of
these things
with Grace and she accommodated herself
to the world as it is she didn't just
live in the past you didn't have to dust
her off okay
she she wore modern clothing with
dignity
with class
she after the September 11th attacks in
the United States she bucked a 600 year
old tradition she had the guard outside
the palace play The Star-Spangled Banner
it's quite revolutionary well not really
no
there's there's something deeper there
it's in it's it's sort of the way that
uh if you want to be an avant-god guard
artist you need to know how to paint
first you know when young people they
don't want to actually learn anything
about a craft or or an art form so they
say no I'm just going to be free form
and avant-garde you'll say well before
you become avant-garde maybe you become
guard you know maybe figure out how to
paint first and then then you can become
more abstract
and because Elizabeth
was so reverent toward the tradition so
she had a perspective not of resentment
for her ancestors but of gratitude to
the people who come before her came
before her and to the people who were
her subjects because she was so steeped
in Tradition and so reverent were the
tradition
she she could recognize when
circumstances called to Buck a tradition
and that that was an organic sort of
change and it meant quite a lot to the
people of the United States I remember I
remember when it happened I was a little
kid but I remember it
that
is a a lasting Legacy that is something
that we don't see anymore and the
antipathy toward the royal family as
such
there have been all sorts of Royals
who've had all sorts of done all sorts
of terrible things in many ways it makes
Elizabeth even more admirable because
she withstood them
and the the most emotion she ever showed
as she had all of these awful scandals
of her children and the divorces and the
terror attacks in her country and all
these awful things she referred to it as
the anus oribilis
she even when she's expressing emotion
she does it in Latin okay this woman
just
just had courage and this woman had
dignity and had a stiff upper lip now
today you think of young people who you
know that a random person they meet on
the street won't refer to them by their
imaginary pronoun and they break down in
tears
but meanwhile you've got this woman who
has lived and lived through and led her
country through major tragedies keeps a
stiff upper lip
and remains grateful
and the the kind of
reflexive antipathy I think that a lot
of people have especially some Americans
have for the royal family I think that's
a mistake too
because it it comes from a I think an
undue elevation of the meritocracy
we say well the only people who should
have privileges are the people who earn
those Privileges and there's something
to that obviously you want people to
accomplish things you want people to
earn things
you don't want an unfair unjust system
but meritocracy is a really slippery
tricky thing and it gives way very
easily to Pride and at at the most basic
level there there can be no such thing
as a pure meritocracy because we are all
given such privilege
the very the fact that you were born in
the United States if you're listening
people listen from all over the world I
suppose the very fact that you were born
in the west let's say wherever you were
born the very fact that you were born at
all is a privilege you could have been
killed in the womb as many people are
in fact if you had some parents
for it's quite a privilege two parents
married together and you grew up in
their hassle that's an amazing privilege
if you were raised by anybody at all
that's a privilege too
the people that you chance to meet along
the way
The Helpful priest I don't know the nice
guy at the deli counter that you meet
who gives you some advice who gives you
some encouragement someone in your in
your life who gave you a break gave you
a lucky break maybe
in your career and yes you earn things
you work hard true but but we shouldn't
allow the fact that we have earned
certain things and accomplished certain
things to uh to give us a swell head and
to make us lose sight of so much that we
have been given
because then we will discard it we will
cast it away and that's what we are
doing with our cultural inheritance here
in the United States
Queen Elizabeth was born Royal
and then
because of
happenstance because of the twists Of
Fortune or Providence maybe she came
into the line of the royal throne
and then she ruled her country
she was given immense privileges of
course palaces castles
and she
fulfilled the duty that came with those
privileges
when we when we in this imagined pure
meritocracy that we all flatter
ourselves that we're living in
when we deny the real privileges that we
have all been given
and it's much easier to deny the duty as
well
and we do deny that Duty
we frequently do
we we talk only from the perspective of
Rights the left in America talks only
from the perspective of rights that you
have you have a right to I don't know
you have a right to be called whatever
fake pronoun you make up you have a
right to someone else's money you're
right you're a right to this you are
right to that but but the conservatives
do this too the conservatives view
politics very often
through the lens of Rights I have my
right to my gun I have my right to my
this I have my right to my that yeah
sure we do have some rights whatever
happened to duty whatever happened to
sacrifice whatever happened to the
Natural bonds of loyalty that we have
the very moment we're born into this
world born into a family and into a
community and into a country and into
and and all underneath the the
Providence and the kingship of our
creator
the duty that we have to our god what
happened to that
you don't hear people talk about that
anymore one of the last people you heard
talk about that was the lady who died
today
and I think it's one of the reasons that
that people feel that they will miss her
so much and the people are so affected
by her death
the woman
finished the race
she did what she was called on by her
country and by history to do and she
said a very good example and she endured
that whole time
uh she was
I think Far and Away the noblest and
most admirable public figure in my
lifetime
I think
we all fear that there will not be
another like her that she is the last of
her breed
or at the very least that there won't be
another like her for a very long time
we can pray
that there will be we can pray for the
Repose of her soul
Requiem Scott in Pache we can observe
this was an amazing this was reported by
the British journalists there's some
photos of it I think on Getty Images
as she Lay Dying at Balmoral Balmoral in
Scotland
a double rainbow appeared over
Buckingham Palace
and then
at the very moment
after she died
when they lowered the flags to half-mast
another rainbow appeared over Windsor
Castle
it reminds me of a line from my priest
father George rutler Who quoting
scripture says it's an evil generation
that looks for signs and wonders but
it's a stupid generation that ignores
signs and wonders and when you see these
little signs they're little hints of
Providence I think
a little bit sort of God peeking out
behind the curtain
to remind people that there are things
that are higher we're not just we're not
just meat we're not just flesh we're not
just our lusts and our appetites and our
interests we're not just
Adam atomized individuals clubbing each
other to get a little bit more of an
advantage but there is a Transcendent
moral order to the world there is such a
thing as Justice there is such a thing
as
goodness and rightness and Truth and we
ought to live our lives in accordance
with those things and it might all not
always be
the most celebrated and we might go
through all sorts of travails and
troubles in fact we will we will do that
but it it will be worth it and we can
recognize it even the ones of us who
want to deny that those things exist you
look at a life well lived like that in
service to others and you see you you
recognize that dignity
and you admire it and wood that we could
all live so admirable a life
rest in peace to the queen long live the
king and we'll see you tomorrow on the
show